if there is a way out of the war in
Ukraine Igor serduk and his wife Tatiana
have found it in rural Ireland where
they now live as refugees
but there's something at home in the
region of Curson that pulls them back
Igor is the director of one of kurson's
biggest schools and his college is
situated on the edge of the front line
foreign
some miniature movie so
many times
this is important
Professor Sir Duke lives with 300
Ukrainian refugees in this Equestrian
Center in County Cork and he's grateful
to be here
many of his fellow teachers face grave
danger in Curson
is
foreign
this is the college in the city of Nova
kakovka
the windows have been smashed and some
of the classrooms destroyed but Igor is
still running it
from the Charming Tea Room in County
Cork
he directs operations from this table
using computer apps and the phone when
he can get a signal hello
hello
hello
Igor got through to one of his students
in the cookery program
his student sent us a video as she did
her assignment
she can't use the facilities of the
college so she prepares the dish at home
and she asked us to hide her identity
the Ukrainian curriculum has been
outlawed by the Russians
next Igor calls one of his instructors
they use the internet to distribute
school work but direct contact is always
tricky
the teachers called Sergey and he says
the Russians are moving troops and
Equipment into Nova kakovka the
ukrainians target them with missile
strikes but when they're intercepted by
the Russians the missiles often land in
the city
[Music]
professor said you spent two weeks in
prison after refusing to implement the
Russian curriculum that's why he decided
to flee but Igor says he'll return when
the enemy is defeated
the banks of the river Blackwater
provide some Sanctuary but they do not
offer peace of mind for a man with
hundreds of students to teach
John Sparks Sky News in Mill Street
Ireland